do you have any confidence that there
will be any flight that takes off
departing this country to rwanda
look this is a mess that pretty patel
created she was told that the system was
unworkable
unethical ethical and would cost an
extraordinary amount of money it was
very unlikely
that she would be able to get a system
up and running as quickly as possible
given that the israelis tried and didn't
succeed the australians tried and didn't
succeed so she was warned about this and
of course we're now in this situation
can you blame her for trying i mean we
we counted yesterday minimum 250 people
including young children coming across
the channel yesterday in almost perfect
conditions you and i both know that if
the weather had been worse lives would
almost inevitably have been lost can you
blame pretty patel for throwing the dice
and trying to do something to stop
deaths in the channel
how do you deal with that look the first
thing you do is you negotiate with your
french your belgian your europol
partners you invest in police you invest
in intelligence you deal with supply
chain issues that can come as far from
china to deal with the criminal gangs
the second thing you need is a
deal with europe now that we're out of
the european convention there is no
dublin convention that means that we can
send people back to the european union
who are not entitled to remain uh in our
country she hasn't done that and of
course the other thing you've got to do
is deal with the asylum backlog people
are waiting up to five years it's
costing taxpayers money to put people up
um in hotels your viewers will have seen
the cues uh at heathrow and gatwick they
know what it's like dealing with a
passport office well it's even worse
with the asylum systems where you can
wait for five years that's how you deal
with the problems in the english
challenge that that may very well be the
case so why then are they not doing this
are you genuinely suggesting that the
tories to a man and a woman are so
opposed to people being able to seek
asylum in this country that they're
willing to to do this is that is that
your argument well the first thing to
say is of course there's a lot of
concern on the conservative
bench about this scheme it feels like
it's a manufactured row they knew they
actually said that it was unlikely that
they would get this through the courts
once they set it up it's a distraction i
don't think that's entirely fair i don't
think that's entirely fair i think i
think yesterday i think there was there
was a degree of confidence at the home
office that the flight would take off
because they had not heard from the
european court on human rights it was
very much a last-minute intervention it
doesn't to his coffee i mean she was
sitting where you are
roughly an hour ago i mean she said i
was incredibly surprised never seen a
decision from the court that late in the
day i don't know why she was surprised
people raised the issue of rwanda's
human rights record they raised the
issues of torture they raised the issues
that concern people who were lgbtq going
back to rwanda and the court and others
have raised that rwanda hasn't got
proper asylum processes which is why
effectively these injunctions have been
issues and the flight has been uh
delayed so all of those issues were
known it's not surprising that we're in
the situation we are this morning do you
think as the prime minister kind of
hinted at yesterday there is any
likelihood that this government would
move forward with with some form of step
some form of legislation that would
remove the convention from huma the
convention on human rights from our law
that would remove the ability of the
european court to intervene in this
fashion
let's be clear winston churchill and
david maxwell fife
conservative politicians were the
architects of our european convention on
human rights
many of your viewers rely on those human
rights human rights that give us
protections in terms of privacy human
rights
different places in our houses well we
would we would all lose out on that
convention that was set up after the
second world war to protect our rights
and rights right across europe uh
because effectively this government
wants a distraction and doesn't actually
want to roll its sleeves up and get on
with the business of dealing with the
problems that exist in our immigration
system but you know because your memory
within the labor party goes back further
than mine you understand the problems
that the last labor government had for
ignoring concerns in parts of the
in parts of the country concerns about
immigration you know this was something
you didn't mention it for for many many
years for fear of being called racist
remember gordon brown and mrs duffy i
was there on that day i mean the labour
party seems to seems to be
not confronting this issue head on when
clearly there is an awful lot of public
dissatisfaction with and i hate to be so
brutal about it dead babies in the
channel well let's be clear the labour
party has not been in power for 12 years
of course this is their asylum
system which has huge backlogs this is
their asylum system where they have no
relationship with france so they can't
create safe routes they can't create a
processing system and they can't
actually deal
with the claims that are being made they
can't strike a deal that sends people
back and they're not dealing with
criminal gangs their system 12 years in
power and we've got an asylum system
that's worse significantly worse year on
year than france then germany then spain
all of whom have bigger claims for
asylum than we do
let's
change topics slightly and as things
currently stand scotland is not a
foreign nation so technically not part
of your brief but if nicola sturgeon has
our way it would be what is the labour
party's position on a second
independence referendum can you rule it
out at any point for the next 10 years
would it be something that you could
count categorically we are a unionist
party we believe in the union we can
rule that out categorically is the
branch office in glasgow going to be
saying exactly the same thing yes great
good to hear on cursed armor though
there is a a suggestion
from within the shadow cabinet that he
hasn't been faring on all cylinders that
he hasn't been hitting it you know we've
got people you know from the top down
briefing journalist that he needs to
give it a bit more welly what do you
need to hear from secure stammer ahead
of conference season which is fast
approaching of course
be if he is to take this party into the
next general election
look we're up in the polls
we were
so on our downers two and a half years
ago after uh that election the the worst
results since 1935 he has done an
incredible job dealing with the issues
within the labour party particularly the
issues around anti-semitism uh
reorientating us so we're looking into
the country we did well in the local
elections no one's complaining about him
within the cabinet
he's doing a fantastic job and frankly
the title tattle that exists uh in a
small part of the newspapers is not our
concern and should not distract us from
the job ahead well the coverage of his
performance at the last pmq's shortly
after boris johnson has had a very
bloody nose that wasn't made up it's not
tittle tattle i mean the coverage of of
kirsten's response to boris johnson
the last pmq's was almost uniformly
negative look uh i'm i'm pretty sure
that in a week or so time we're going to
be discussing by-election results and
the poor performance of the conservative
party that's going to be the debate
labour is moving forward we're moving
forward very well under kirsten's
leadership it's not just down to
kierstama it's down to all of us on the
front bench all of us within the
parliamentary labour party and i think
we're in a very very strong place if we
stay united and committed and clear in
our direction in relation to speaking to
the british people uh we're in a very
strong position to win the next general
election mr lambie good to have you in
the studio thanks for joining us